cela dit mon dieu qu'est que c'était une
arnaque casting alors depuis le début
leur mexicana ma carrière de grandes
comédiennes et d'hermine et
[ __ ] alors tu as une bouteille de jus
de fruits à côté de toi tu n'ouvres tu
prends avait pas dessus du louvre où tu
prends un verre tu te sers tu bois et
quand tu as bu tu dis mexicana la
fraîcheur du mexique tant que c'est
parti
[Applaudissements]
je veux prix mexicana oui
je peux pour des semblants alors
[Musique]
mexicana
la pression du bixi alors tu me fais
sans le ou la vache
mexicana la boisson fraîche du mexique
c'est pas ça le texte mexicaine à la
fraîcheur du mexique je revois
les
siens s'arrache
[Applaudissements]
mais fiona la fraîcheur du mexique
attentes en
asie non
ça va
mexico la fraîcheur du mexique
ces partis
n'ont pas de ça avec monsieur mexicaine
mexicana bois
j'ai presque fini robert way a préservé
son
top ça me rappelle les verts de l'armée
quand on est passé de 2 ou 3 jours mais
on a depuis sa maîtresse
mexicana la fraîcheur du mexique
[Musique]